interrogé sur la présence discrète du
vice premier ministre irakien paris le
porte-parole de l'elysée a déclaré ce
n'est pas une nouvelle affaire à bages
tout le monde était au courant
réaction similaire d'alain juppé qui
accompagne le président l'île maurice à
l'occasion du sommet de la francophonie
écoutez les autorités de l'état en tout
été consulté lorsque cette demande
d'autorisation a été présenté elles ont
donné leur accord et chez tariq aziz qui
est vice premier ministre est que plus
avec qui voyagent beaucoup d'ailleurs y
compris aux états unis à new york elle
était autorisée à se faire hospitaliser
en france ça fait un grand bond de pays
qui ont des relations avec l'irak
la france a d'ailleurs accepté récemment
comme d'autres qu'il y ait une section
d'atterrir à qui je le rappelle notre
objectif vis-à-vis de l'irak est
d'obtenir la mise en oeuvre des
résolutions du conseil de sécurité rien
de plus il s'agit là un geste
humanitaire et je le répète toutes les
autorisations ont été données en ce sens